I told that story recently I had a Karen
come up to me after the show yeah and
she got all up in my face and she goes
that story you told about the Uber
driver was racist and I said well what
part about that was racist and she goes
how do you know he was Mexican I said
I'll tell you how I know he was Mexican
Karen
he had a portrait of the Last Supper
airbrushed on his tailgate okay
that's how the [__] I know he was
Mexican Karen
you're coming at the wrong one Karen
I happen to be a fan of airbrush
tailgates and only Mexicans are keeping
them alive
I would simply like to say gracias
I live in Southern California y'all I've
seen some beautiful Jesus pieces on the
back of
this okay so maybe you're the racist
Karen clearly you've never been to San
Bernardino
foreign